let's see who is next let's go to our
caller from the 503 area code who's
calling today from five zero three well
yeah that's you okay cool
sorry my area code is off I live in
Idaho now but my name's Austin I just
had a question regarding the 2020
election and you know there's a couple
like left wing commentators on YouTube
and what brought this up in the past Tom
Hartman is one of them Sam cedar just
did a segment not too long ago and so
guarding the idea about you know Trump
attempting to invalidate the election
result if in fact loses I haven't been
one to sign on to that idea for that
notion for a while now but the more and
more I watched Bill bar and the more and
more you know this impeachment rolls out
and I see the public reaction on the
right
you know Trump's base reacting to the
impeachment in their rhetoric rounded
I'm really worried that there is a
significant possibility of maybe not
being successful but it being very very
damaging to our country you know long
term you know to our institution to you
know public opinion about you know how
politics works or how elections are
supposed to work and I just want to make
a few points on that maybe let you
respond to them okay so my first point
to that would be you know what do you
need to try to use serve power or you
know invalidate election results or you
know establish yourself as an
authoritarian whatever well you would
need enough public support right
obviously you would need enough public
support and you would need like a
die-hard almost cultish like following
and Trump has that you know we've talked
about you and other people have talked
about the you know almost one-third of
the country that's very very supportive
almost cult-like of the president and
obviously his court might be higher than
that but there's that one third that
never breaks right then you have the
backing in the Congress you have Senate
Republicans that so far and people in
the house I should say Republican that
so far we haven't found something that
they're real
willing to not eventually just break on
and then follow Trump on right
eventually did break even if they give
like flowery you know rhetoric against
him eventually they do and then you have
in the Supreme Court I want to mention
that as well and then the scariest of
them all in my opinion is Bill bark I
mean bill bar to me if this was ever to
go down bill bar would be the one to try
to hold it up legally in the Supreme
Court and make it and tie things up in
the Supreme Court legally making the
case that there was some sort of fraud
that there was summary there's some
reason to you know postpone the election
results and keep Trump in power
temporarily and he'd be the person
trying to work that route and then
trumpet be the person you know during
the PR campaign around it and I think
Bill burr unfortunately might be the
brain so here's my okay I think so
here's my Center I think it is very
likely that if Donald Trump loses he
will informally try to question the
results to claim that it was an unfair
election to claim that he was robbed to
claim that he didn't really lose I don't
think it will actually be anything that
becomes formal for a couple of reasons
number one although he has that third
support I think it is very likely that
whether Trump wins or loses the
electoral college he's gonna lose the
popular vote much like he did in 2016
maybe maybe by even more and typically
for these types of you know for staying
in power in that way to work you often
need to have the military behind you and
I don't think Trump has the military and
the generals it's insane to me to say
this because normally we don't say will
be okay because of the generals in the
military often we're trying to restrain
them and what they're going to do but I
actually think that Donald Trump tried
to remain in power I don't believe that
the military would allow it and I don't
think that he would succeed so I fully
expect that he is going to try a lot of
the things you're saying I do not
believe that it will work can I just ask
one more quick really really quick
follow-up you know would what would bill
bars role or or influence be over the
military in fact events like because you
said you know he can handcuff him to
that desk of the
yeah but eventually they come and remove
them doesn't doesn't that doesn't that
order or that request go to bill bar
first and then he says okay go couldn't
we do what what influence does the
Admiral I don't know you know I don't
want to give the wrong answer but I
don't I think ultimately it would be up
to the military to say Trump is no
longer president and he has to go and
there's no question that bill bar
through the Justice Department could try
to do things but ultimately I don't
believe that it is up to bar as bad of a
player as bar is I don't think in that
case bar is the one who decides I may be
wrong and we should look into it but I
don't think so okay thank you so much
David love the show about it thank you
so much appreciate the phone call happy
Holidays to you that is all the time we
have today sorry to everybody I did not
get to but we will take calls again
still more opportunities to get on the
air with us this year we will take a
quick break and be back with so much
more right after this